(muffled traffic)
- Here.
(thud of cell phone hitting
and sliding on hard floor)
♪ Weight of the world on his ♪
- [Interviewer] All right Coco.
- [Coco] Hey
- [Interviewer] Coco, what
neighborhood did you grow up in?
- [Coco] I grew up in downtown
L.A., like Skid Row area.
- [Interviewer] You grew up in Skid Row?
- Mmm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] That's unusual.
Not a lot of people can say that.
- I know, that's crazy
'cause a lot of times
when I tell people that,
they don't believe me.
They like, "Really, Skid Row?"
- [Interviewer] Nobody grows up there
- Yeah. I did, actually.
- [Interviewer] Did you
stay in one of the hotels?
- I sure did, I stayed
in the Frontier Hotel.
- [Interviewer] Oh, the
famous Frontier Hotel.
- I remember like it was yesterday.
I literally stayed like on the 12th floor.
- [Interviewer] One of
my favorite topics--
- Really?
- [Interviewer] Mean guy here in Skid Row
he's the Frontier Hotel.
- Really?
- [Interviewer] I've heard
so many crazy crazy stories
about that place.
- There's some crazy
stories about that place.
- [Interviewer] Tell me what you've seen.
- Um I--
- [Interviewer] Living there.
- I've seen a lot of stuff in there.
Like, literally I lived there for like
over seven years.
I've seen people jump off buildings.
I've seen dead people inside of rooms.
I've been walked inside of
rooms and people was having sex.
I done seen it all, literally.
- [Interviewer] I'm sure, yeah.
- Like, I've seen it all.
- [Interviewer] It's
the most notorious hotel
I've ever heard of.
- It's a good hotel now, but--
- [Interviewer] Yeah, now it's fixed up.
- it was, yes.
It was an experience.
- [Interviewer] Now it's the Roswell.
- Yeah, it was an experience.
- [Interviewer] So, tell
me about your childhood.
Did you have both your parents?
- Um, I did.
I had my mom and my dad,
but since my mom was like a drug dealer
she was like, in and out
of jail a lot, you know,
so I was more like, just like,
with my mom and my dad on and off,
but I was like, really just
like, by myself really too.
- [Interviewer] They left you alone a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But any, any crazy abuse?
Nothing like that.
You just kinda were left alone.
- Um not crazy abuse or
anything like that, but
I, I got molested a lot
like when I was a kid.
- [Interviewer] By who?
- By my brother's friends.
- [Interviewer] What age were you?
- I was like ten.
Like ten to probably like fourteen.
- [Interviewer] Is that a
pretty common occurrence in...
- I don't know.
- [Interviewer] I mean
I've heard it so many times
from some of the girls
working the streets.
- Probably, like yeah,
for pretty girls like
you know, even though I was like younger
like, I used to be like
you know, nice body
and stuff like that so...
I don't think it's pretty normal because
that's just not normal
for you to want to touch a girl
like underage, but I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I've heard it a lot.
- Yeah?
- [Interviewer] And then what age were you
when you left your mom's care
and went out on your own?
- Um okay so I had my
first son at fifteen.
So I was probably like thirteen, fourteen
like when I was like on my own, ya know?
- [Interviewer] Thirteen,
fourteen, living where?
- I was living in The Huntington.
The Huntington Hotel like on eighth and
Main.
- [Interviewer] So, how
does a 13 year old girl
get to stay at a hotel on her own?
- You know what?
I used to break into the rooms.
I was illegally living there.
I used to break into the
rooms when I was younger
and just go up in there
and sleep in the rooms
like, it wasn't monitored.
There was never any security
there was nothing like,
there was nobody ya know?
So, I just used to break into the rooms
sleep up in there and then, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Were you working then?
- Like prostituting?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Mmm-hmmm.
- [Interviewer] And you
would bring guys there?
- No.
I just, I just--
no one knew about it.
I was just only working like
on the streets, you know?
It was--
I couldn't tell my parents
they would uh-uh...they
would've probably--
- [Interviewer] Sorry, 13 year
old girl working the streets,
you'd pick up a guy
and then you guys go where?
- To the hotels, in the car,
or something like that,
just different things.
A alley.
- [Interviewer] A 13 year old girl,
you know, how old are you now?
- Twenty-four.
- [Interviewer] Twenty-four.
So, at thirteen is there like
a high demand for this young girl?
More than a 24 year old?
- [Coco] Well, yeah.
Well, it's a different like,
it's a different westerning now like
I don't know like
versus like when I first started.
It was high demand for everybody.
Like now, I think like it's just like
watered down, and people are just
I don't know what the
world has come to honestly
I don't know, but
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] And do you
have any kids of your own?
- [Coco] I do.
I have two kids.
I have a 8 year old son
and I have a 9 month old daughter.
- [Interviewer] And you're
raising them yourself?
- [Coco] Yeah.
Well, not my son.
My son is with his dad.
I just raise my daughter.
- [Interviewer] How did your
second child's father die?
- [Coco] He got shot.
- [Interviewer] Gang again?
- [Coco] I don't know.
I don't really like
talking about it, honestly.
- [Interviewer] You working with pimps
or without pimps or...
- [Coco] I work alone.
I work for myself.
I've had pimps, but I don't really...
- [Interviewer] What's the
upside and the downside?
- [Coco] Of pimps?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Coco] Well I just feel like
I'm just too grown to be like
askin' people for stuff like.
So that's like a downside for me,
like I don't feel like
I should have to like
wake up and ask somebody to feed me or
ask somebody to buy me
something to wear or whatever.
Like, you know, like,
that's a downside to me
because if I'm making the money,
I should be able to do whatever
I want to do with it like.
The upside of having
a pimp I think a lot--
some people be saying
like it's not protection,
but it is, like you
know, like I don't know.
It's not really no upsides that much.
I don't know it's just
for me, a pimp is like having a boyfriend,
like just somebody to
like have good sex with or
I don't know, different stuff.
- [Interviewer] And typically,
they'll intimidate you
into the relationship?
- Do they intimidate me?
- [Interviewer] No, no, I
mean like a lot of pimps
seem to be like, they use intimidation or
with the girls to get them to work.
No?
- Nah, not for me.
Normally these guys like,
they sweet talk me.
They don't intimidate.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see.
- Yeah, they like,
seduce me I think.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- That's how I get with the guys.
I get seduced.
Like, they start trying to rub a booty and
I don't know...
- [Interviewer] Tell you
what you want to hear.
- Yeah, basically.
- [Interviewer] And does this
work get to you sometimes?
Does it get you down?
- Yeah, a lot of times.
Because I just feel
like I could do better.
Like, even though the money is good,
I just feel like,
where am I really gonna get
selling my pussy all my life?
Like...
Where?
Nowhere.
'Cause, it's just like a
repeated cycle with it,
like you just wake up,
you did the same thing over
and over like and you not--
- [Interviewer] And
you're not saving money,
you're not putting--
- No and literally spending money.
All the money I make I
spend it and like you know
or I give it to somebody pimp or
I don't know whatever.
You know, I'm like...yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any plans?
Anything you'd like to see
happen in the next five,
five years for you?
- Yeah, eventually I wanna
leave all these pimps alone
and get myself together.
Save up like ten thousand dollars
because I wanna open
this catering truck like,
I see myself like owning a catering truck
like I been looking into it a lot, like
and you can typically make
like ten thousand dollars
off a catering truck in a month.
And a truck is only about like
fifteen thousand dollars like
I don't know, but I really
I wanna do that like.
- [Interviewer] That's a great idea.
- I actually got somebody
who's willing to invest in me,
but I don't even want to
take his money because
I feel like I'm not gonna do
what's right with it right now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I don't.
He gonna give me that ten thousand dollars
and I'm gonna go on a
goddamn shopping spree.
(laughing)
I'm serious.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have a lot of friends
that do the same thing?
- Mmm-hmmm all my friends.
I don't hang out with people
that don't do what I do.
- [Interviewer] Of the girls
that you went to high school,
how many of them do this for a living?
- Um I never really went to high school.
Yeah, I did graduate high school though.
But, I graduated high
school in juvenile halls.
- [Interviewer] I see.
- Yeah.
So...
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What do you
wish was different about
your childhood that
may have redirected it?
- I wish I didn't get molested
because like
when I was getting molested,
I thought it was okay, you know?
And I low-key became
addicted to sex, no lie.
Like when the guy stopped molesting
like I wanted sex like
so bad, like you know,
like so like I wish like that that
would have never happened to me
because it like fucked me
up to the point where like
I thought it was okay to
just go around fucking
like, having sex with different men, like,
just for the fun of it, like I don't know.
- [Interviewer] And you
were at what age, ten?
- The who?
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was like eleven and then like
he stopped, I stopped,
he stopped molesting me
when I was like thirteen.
I recently seen that guy
too, that's so crazy.
And I seen him and I said hi to him
and he was like,
he told me like
you got me jumped, you got me beat up
He was like I hate you I hope you die,
and I was like, "Wait! What?" (laughs)
He was like you got me beat up like,
and I'm like, I didn't know
what he was talking about,
but he just like, got on like, you know?
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] And where do you work now?
On Figaro?
- Yes.
I work Fig and Western.
- [Interviewer] And Western is where?
West...
- [Coco] Western and 51st Street
- [Interviewer] Western and 51st?
- [Coco] You don't know Western?
- [Interviewer] I don't make
it down there very often.
- [Coco] No?
- [Interviewer] I'll have
to come check it out.
- Yes you will.
- [Interviewer] If I see
you I'll pick you up.
(laughing)
Alright.
'Cause I'll be looking at you
like, "Oh he's a cop, no."
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
everybody thinks that.
- But I know ya now!
No I'm playing.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Well thank
you so much for talking to me.
- No problem.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with everything.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Good luck
with your food truck.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Alright.